dear woman from the EM Lyon
to get rid of a gas supplier
who is waging a brutal war of aggression Putin
they have looked for us one
who fights a brutal war of aggression
alias even if many german media are silent
currently invades the oil dictatorship
who declares to be a trusted partner
they became the democratic Armenia
Respect for this choice
after all lies our new best buddy
Azerbaijan in the matter of democracy
Press and civil liberties
still far behind Russia
only when bribing corrupt CDU hongs is Alice
at the very front when they started their service here I thought
they were just in and 1 bit criminal
by now I know
that they are also impressively moral
I can't think of anything more about the EU 1
except we should not leave Europe to the lines